oh Gott ich wollte einmal den Blutdruck
noch mal kontrollieren bei dir drei
Jahre Corona für Pflegeeinrichtungen ist
die Pandemie immer noch eine große
Herausforderung
testisolations- und maskenpflicht gelten
hier immer noch während dem öffentlichen
Leben Maßnahmen langsam aufgehoben
werden vor Lockerungen in
Pflegeeinrichtungen warnt die Barmer
Ersatzkasse die heute ihren Pflegereport
vorstellt
dass die corona-krise in den
Pflegeheimen nicht vorbei ist die
Pflegeheime sind weiter Hotspots wir
konnten zum Beispiel feststellen dass im
Juli diesen Jahres 40 Mal so viele
Pflegekräfte im Pflegeheimen wegen einer
corona-infektion krankgeschrieben waren
als im Juli des letzten Jahres
doch Schutzmaßnahmen wie das Tragen von
Masken erschwere die Kommunikation
erheblich so die Erfahrung der
Pflegerinnen und Pfleger im
schmalenbachhaus ST marien im Sauerland
viele Bewohner Kommunikation oder nehmen
auch ganz viel wahr über die nonverbale
Kommunikation also so Gesichtszüge und
alles und das ist da ist die
Kommunikation dann manchmal schon
gestürzt dann auch die Kosten der
corona-schutzmaßnahmen werden zum
Problem bei ständigen Personalausfällen
durch corona-infektion muss der Träger
kurzfristig Ersatz organisieren
Mitarbeiter von teuren Personalagenturen
anheuern eine erheblicher Kostenfaktor
wenn die alle positiv sind oder vermehrt
positiv sind eine Quarantäne sind dann
brauchen Sie Leute um die Dienste müssen
abgedeckt werden und das hat auch dann
eben
das wird teurer dann haben wir schon
Masken also Masken tragen gehen wir
jetzt 5000 Euro im Monat mehr für aus
die haben wir vorher nicht gehabt
kosten die umgelegt werden müssen
auch in der evangelischen Heimstiftung
in Stuttgart nehmen Sie die Pandemie
weiter ernst Hygiene und Schutzkonzepte
seien gut erprobt dennoch sei es Zeit
Lockerungen einzuführen die Menschen die
dort arbeiten und die dort leben die
erwarten einfach auch eine Normalität
zurück die ja jetzt der Öffentlichkeit
zurückgegeben wird die Menschen können
frei entscheiden ob sie jetzt sie eine
Gaststätte gehen oder auf den
Weihnachtsmarkt gehen in den
Pflegeeinrichtungen wird den
pflegebedürftigen Menschen immer noch
zugemutet dass sie eine Maske aufsetzen
wenn sie zu einer
Gemeinschaftsveranstaltung gehen die
meisten Heimbewohner hätten bei einer
corona-infektion inzwischen auch nur
noch einen relativ mildenverlauf so die
Argumentation
und darüber möchte ich jetzt sprechen
mit dem Bundesgesundheitsminister Karl
Lauterbach schön guten Morgen Herr
Minister guten Morgen
pflegeheime sind nach wie vor Corona
Hotspots das ist im Grunde der Tenor des
Reports welche sagen wir mal drei
Schlüsse ziehen sie jetzt daraus zum
einen dass wir sehr vorsichtig in den
Pflegeeinrichtungen gewesen sind noch
weiter sind das ist richtig wir müssen
die Menschen dort schützen das sind auch
jetzt noch zu viele die deutsche sterben
aber diese Maßnahmen Medikamente
Impfungen Schutzmaßnahmen die haben sich
bewährt zum zweiten ich hoffe dass wir
im nächsten Jahr in eine andere
Situation hineinkommen dass es dann
besser wird also ich meine jetzt so
Geduld
in diesem letzten schweren Winter ist es
eben wichtig dass wir noch mal
zusammenhalten und zum dritten Mann
danke gilt natürlich alle Menschen die
dort arbeiten denn die Arbeit ist schwer
ich besuche viele Pflegeeinrichtungen
und das ist etwas was man nicht auf
genug sagen darf das ist eine sehr
schwere Arbeit und vielen Dank an all
diejenigen die tun was wir können zu
stützen danke ist schön freut man sich
drüber genauso wie der Applaus der
gerade zu Beginn auch der pandemia auch
von vielen Bürgern und Bürgerinnen aus
der Gesellschaft in Richtung
Pflegekräfte dann gespendet wurde und
doch fühlen sich genau diese
Pflegekräfte in vielen Bereichen und
auch schon länger im Stich gelassen
zudem gibt es jetzt auch ein Ergebnis
des pflegereports so stark von Corona
Betroffene Pflegekräfte wie nie zuvor
was heißt das jetzt also die
Schutzmaßnahmen wie Maske etc bleiben
erstmal erhalten ja sonst hätten wir ja
noch mehr Ausfälle wenn wir zum Beispiel
die isolationspflicht aufheben würden
was ja manchmal gefordert wird dann
gingen Menschen infiziert zur Arbeit
wurden dort andere Mitarbeiterinnen
Mitarbeiter anstecken es wird noch mehr
ausfahren und wir würden die dort wohnen
die Bewohner gefährden das kann man
nicht machen wir müssen darauf setzen
dass es wirklich noch mal ein schwerer
Winter wird es wird noch mal eine Welle
kommen aber dann wird es ja auch besser
dann geht es auch voran wir können die
Lockerungen also uns vorstellen in
Zukunft aber im Moment ist wirklich wir
sind vor einer letzten winterwelle das
müssen wir noch einmal schaffen da hatte
ich den Zusammenhalt für das wichtigste
gibt es aber auch etliche
Pflegeeinrichtungen die sagen wir wollen
das so wie die Bundesländer auch selber
entscheiden also wir wollen uns das
nicht mehr vorschreiben lassen was mit
Impfungen ist oder aber auch mit den
Maßnahmen die Sie gerade angesprochen
haben würden sie dem nicht folgen nein
also wir müssen hier die Regel vorgeben
sonst wird ja auch einen Druck aufgebaut
auf die Pflegekräfte dann sagt zum
Beispiel der private Betreiber wenn ihr
euch infiziert habt dann müsst ihr zur
Arbeit kommen ich will dass der Umsatz
stimmt dass das weitergeht und was weiß
ich wir sind ja auch in der Situation
was über die Pflegekräfte schützen
müssen übrigens auch Pflegekräfte können
long kovident entwickeln viele
Pflegekräfte sind krank geworden daher
hier so großzügig zu sagen also das
entscheidet der Arbeitgeber darauf
liefer ist ja meistens hinaus das hatte
ich nicht für richtig da müssen wir die
Pflegekräfte und die Angehörigen auch
schützen das geht nicht anders und wie
gesagt mit die Maßnahmen müssen mit
Augenmaß eingesetzt werden wir haben
über den Sommer hinweg viel vorbereitet
die Medikamente werden schneller gegeben
die helfen die im Lücken bei den
Pflegebedürftigen werden geschlossen und
die allermeisten die in der Pflege
arbeiten haben sich auch impfen lassen
das ist auch großartig da auch damals
nicht immer ganz freiwillig ja aber sehr
viele auch freiwillig und viele die
freiwillig gemacht haben fahren es
trotzdem richtig dass es Pflicht ist
weil man muss sich aufeinander verlassen
können die Pflegekräfte haben sich auch
gegenseitig geschützt jetzt ist es so
dass einige Bundesländer und das ist ja
auch deren Recht die isolationspflicht
bereits aufgehoben haben ist denn die
isolationspflicht bei der nächsten
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz dann sie
wird sicherlich Thema sein und danach
dann auch Geschichte also gibt es dann
im Grunde bis auf die Maske noch im nah
und Fernverkehr im Grunde keine Vorgaben
mehr sich das richtig nein also ich
glaube nicht dass es so kommen wird ich
will jetzt diese Konferenz nicht
vorgreifen aber es sind ja keine neuen
Argumente dazu gekommen ich bin ja auch
mit denjenigen die wollen dass sie die
Situation nicht aufheben im Gespräch
aber wir sind jetzt also am Vorabend in
einer besonders ansteckenden Variante
wahrscheinlich werden wir mit der bq1.12
Variante ringen müssen die ist noch
ansteckender die Zahlen fangen schon
wieder an zu steigen die also Verläufe
sind nicht harmloser geworden deshalb
sollten wir so Risiko gehen wir müssen
die Beschäftigten schützen wir müssen
die auch Menschen mit Risikofaktoren
schützen viele Krebskranke Menschen oder
Menschen die eine Chemotherapie gerade
machen nur herzkranke Menschen für die
ist der Verlauf schwer und für jeden der
schon long kurvitat ist jeder weitere
Infektion ein Risiko das sind ja auch
hunderttausende die Variante bq11 die
Sie angesprochen haben da heißt es die
ist wohl etwas höher aber nicht ganz so
bedrohlich in Österreich kursiert die
gerade schon und Christian Drosten hat
gesagt dass es eine von drei Varianten
aber insgesamt wenn man sich die Zahlen
anschaut gerade was die Infektionszahlen
angelegt geht es ja in den letzten zwei
drei Monaten im Grunde so ein bisschen
auf und ab und das sah ein Zeichen für
das kommende Ende der Pandemie schließen
sie sich dem Direktor der Virologie der
Berliner Charité an sind wir dann durch
wir sind ja im engen Austausch und ich
kenne die Argumentation von Christian
draußen ich will ihm da nicht
widersprechen hatte mich aber etwas
zurück
ich hoffe dass es so kommt und es war
sozusagen übrigens wir hatten im Herbst
eine gravierende herbstwelle hohe
fahrtzahl und dass wir jetzt noch eine
sehr starke Übersterblichkeit haben es
schaue mir derzeit viel mehr Menschen
als um diese Jahreszeit typischerweise
in Deutschland und wir haben auch noch
immer fast 1000 Tote pro Woche mit
Corona das ist auch dieser frühen Herbst
Welle zu verdanken da laufen noch Fälle
nach man stirbt dann eben an den
Komplikationen aber später und so etwas
muss ich einfach als Gesundheitsminister
versuchen zu beherrschen wir werden bald
durch diese schwere pandemische Lage weg
sein ich sehe da auch nicht am Ende des
Todes ob es genauso sich abspielt wie
bei Christian Dorsten vorher gesagt
warten wir ab aber ich hoffe auf jeden
Fall dass er Recht hat also die
Todesfälle die schwanden tatsächlich
zwischen 162 und 199 innerhalb eines
Tages also auch da Schwankungen zu sehen
ja Minister vielen Dank für das Kommen
Karl Lauterbach war das unter anderem
zum Pfleger Reporter gerade
veröffentlicht wurde danke ihnen sehr
danke